- [Instructor] So let's
imagine this scenario.
It's cold outside
and we want to make a nice hot bowl
of chicken noodle soup.
Well, we'd probably need to
get the ingredients first.
We need some chicken bones
to give the broth that
distinct chicken flavor,
some noodles to add
that starchy component,
carrots and onions to give
some sweetness and color.
And of course, salt and
pepper to provide seasoning.
All of these ingredients
would come together
to make our chicken noodle soup
the comfort food that so many people love,
but this video is supposed
to be about cells.
You know, those tiny things
that make up all living things on earth.
So why am I telling
you about chicken soup?
Well, just like how each
ingredient in chicken soup
adds something unique to
the soup's overall flavor
and texture, a cell's different parts
add something unique and necessary
for the overall functioning of the cell.
So, let's take a look at
some of the structures
inside a cell and see how
their functions come together
to allow cells to carry out
all the processes of life.
So let's explore the parts of a cell
starting with the cell's surface.
Cells are separated from
their outside environment
by a cell membrane.
You can think of the cell
membrane like a fortress gate,
because it regulates what
comes into and out of the cell,
and contained within the cell
is a jelly-like substance
that fills out the cell
and contains its internal parts,
this jelly and all the
structures within it
make up the cell cytoplasm.
Unlike chicken soup,
the cell parts in the cytoplasm
are not just floating around.
Instead, they're organized
and held in place
by an internal structural network.
Some of the parts contained
within the cytoplasm
are called organelles.
So what exactly are organelles?
Well, organelles are small
compartments in the cell
that have different
structures and functions.
The word organelle
basically means, mini organ.
And just like how our bodies
are made up of different organs
that work together to help us stay alive,
cells contain different
organelles that work together
to get things done inside the cell.
For example, these jellybean
shaped organelles here
are little energy producing factories
called mitochondria.
So mitochondria use chemical reactions
to break down sugar molecules
in order to release energy that the cell
can use for other tasks.
Another really amazing
organelle is the nucleus.
You can think of the nucleus
as the information database
of the cell.
It contains DNA which
includes the cell's genes.
Genes are special instructions
that the cell uses to
carry out its functions.
Moving over to a plant cell,
we can see these green
organelles called chloroplasts.
You might remember that plants
carry out photosynthesis.
Well, chloroplasts are the
organelle's responsible
for this process.
Plants need food to live,
just like animals do.
And chloroplasts use photosynthesis
to produce sugars that
plant cells use as food.
Plant cells also have a layer
outside their cell membrane
called the cell wall,
which helps provide
structure for the cell.
So as you can see, there
are so many different parts
that make up a single cell.
There are many, many
organelles present in cells,
way more than the handful
I mentioned in this video.
And what's even more mind blowing
is that these diagrams are
only simplified versions
of what cells actually look like.
And just to give you an idea,
here's a picture of what
a real cell looks like.
So when we're talking about cells
and using these diagrams as references,
keep in mind that these pictures
are only simplified models
of the real thing.
To wrap up this video on cell parts,
let's revisit our delicious
bowl of chicken noodle soup
that I mentioned at the beginning.
Each ingredient that we added
had a unique function that contributed
to the soup's taste and texture.
And similarly, our cell's ingredients,
its organelles and structures,
each contribute a unique function
that helps the cell carry out
all the tasks necessary for life.
So the next time you find yourself
in front of a bowl of noodle soup,
just imagine that you're
eating one enormous cell.
Now, isn't that something to noodle on?